Guten Tag, Aktaqa ist mein Name und ich bin hier aus.
So erst möchte ich ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Person stellen.
Dann kommen wir gleich zu Ihren Beschwören.
Ist das in Ordnung?
Ja, natürlich. Guten Abend. Hallo.
Freut mich, dass ich heute jemand treffen kann.
Wie heißen Sie?
Mein Name ist Manuela Schreiner.
Können Sie bitte Ihren Vornamen und Nachnamen durch?
Ja, einfach. Manuela.
Martha Anton, Nortpol Udo, Emil Ludwig Anton, Manuela.
Und der Nachname ist Schreiner.
Siegfried Caesar Heimrich, SCH.
Richard Emil Ida, Nortpol Emil Richard.
Schreiner.
Manuela Schreiner.
Wie alt sind Sie?
38 Jahre alt.
8, 3, 7, 8.
Wann genau sind Sie geboren?
Am 25. Januar 1987.
Können Sie bitte weiter schlanken?
Am 25. Januar 1985.
Januar 1985.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Schreiner.
Wozu ist das jetzt wichtig?
Warum brauchen Sie meine Größe?
Das ist eine Routine-Music-Frage für das Gespräch.
Ich bin 1,72 m.
Sie wollen sicherlich auch wissen, wie schwer ich bin?
Ja.
Ich bin 85 kg.
Wer ist das Hausarzt?
Mein Hausarzt ist Herr Müller in der Bahnhofsstraße.
Ja, Müller in der Straße.
Was können Sie für Frau Schneider, wer hat das schwer?
Herr Doktor, ich habe seit ungefähr 1 Woche Schmerzen auf meiner linken Seite.
Ich glaube, das ist die Niere hier oben.
Und das wird jetzt schlimm.
Und seit heute ist es ganz schlimm.
Da sind ganz starke Schmerzen.
Und das Straht, also ein bisschen in den Unterbauch und ein bisschen in das Bein.
Aufstrauen.
Hatten Sie einen schweren Frühling?
Nein, das kann ich mich jetzt nicht erinnern.
Ich habe das nicht mehr in der Art von Schmerzen gehabt.
Haben Sie beschwerden, plötzlich oder langsam auftreten?
Wie gesagt, das geht schon seit über 1 Woche.
Diese Schmerzen, aber jetzt seit heute ist es extrem schlimm geworden.
Immer, glaube ich.
Gibt es etwas, das die Schmerzen auslöst?
Und ich unbedingt, also die sind immer da, aber es wird mal mehr, mal weniger.
Und wenn ich auf Toilette gehe zu Wasser lassen, dann habe ich das Gefühl,
dass es dann noch schlimmer wird.
Und manchmal kommen die Schmerzen auch so wellenartig.
Oder wie würde man sagen, so richtige Kohli kennen?
Wie stark die Schmerzen auf einer Skala von 1 bis 10?
Also heute würde ich sagen, schon wirklich sehr, sehr stark.
Bis 7 oder 8 würde ich schon sagen, ich habe hier dann Schmerztabletten genommen.
Daher ist es jetzt ein bisschen besser, aber ich merke,
es wird wieder schlechter.
Welche Medikamente eingenommen?
Also ich habe zu Hause nur Ibuprofen gehabt.
Kennen Sie Dosierung?
Ich glaube, das waren die 600 Milligramm.
Da habe ich heute Morgen schon eins genommen, heute Mittag.
Aber die Schmerzen kommen wir schon wieder.
Sind die Schmerzen dauerhaft oder gehen Sie weg?
Also wie gesagt, jetzt seit heute sind die dauerhaft.
Die werden aber ein bisschen mehr und weniger, aber die sind dauerhaft.
Die Schmerzen sind wellenförmig, richtig?
Also ja, ich würde sagen, wellenförmig oder kodigartig eher.
Okay. Waren Sie deswegen bei einem anderen Arzt gewesen?
Also ich war vor einer Woche beim Hausarzt, aber damals waren die Schmerzen nicht so schlimm.
Er hat auch nichts gemacht.
Er meinte, ich soll erst mal abwarten und hat mir nur Ibuprofen aufgeschrieben.
Damals hatte ich auch die Schmerzen eher im Bereich meines Rückens,
im Bereich der Lendenwirbe.
Genau, und jetzt hat sich das verlagert eher in Richtung Flanke und Unterbau.
Gibt es etwas, dass ich Schmerzen...
Nein, nein, ich habe schon...
Sie haben schon die Frage gestellt, das ist richtig.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Bisher noch nicht, nein.
Nein.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit in letzter Zeit?
Also seit den Schmerzen nicht so stark geworden sind, möchte ich auch nichts essen,
weil mir ist es auch so ein bisschen übel.
Übel?
Ja.
Haben Sie Erbruchen?
Also ich habe eine Übelkeit, aber Erbrochen habe ich bisher noch nicht.
Nein.
Okay.
Haben Sie Geschwindeveränderung?
Haben Sie Abgönnungen oder Sorge?
Nein, nein, nein.
Okay.
Haben Sie Küsten oder Luftnoten?
Nein.
Haben Sie Stotbrinnen?
Nein, habe Übelkeit, aber kein Stotbrinnen.
Okay.
Haben Sie Herzstolpern oder Herzlase?
Brustenge?
Nein, bisher noch nicht.
Nein.
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Stuhlgang?
Stuhlgang nicht, aber ich habe das Gefühl, ich muss sehr oft auf Toilette.
Wenn ich auf Toilette gehe, dann kommt ein bisschen Urin, ist aber wenig.
Aber es brennt auch ein bisschen.
Ich bekomme immer schmerzen, so kolikartige Schmerzen.
Haben Sie in der Nacht, müssen Sie in der Nacht zu Toilette gehen?
Also seit 2-3 Tagen muss ich auch nachts öfters mal aufstehen, weil ich Schmerzen habe.
Haben Sie Schwinde?
Nein.
Haben Sie Unfall oder Verletzung gehen?
Sie waren jetzt oder in der Vorgeschichte?
Jetzt oder früher?
Ja, ja.
Wie meintest du das?
Früher oder in einer Woche?
Also jetzt in letzter Woche habe ich keinen Unfall gehabt, nein.
Aber vor 3 Jahren habe ich mal einen Fahrradunfall gehabt, ja.
Fahrradunfall.
Wann haben Sie diesen Unfall?
Vor 3 Jahren.
Schlafen Sie gut?
Normalerweise ja, bis auf die letzten Tage jetzt, aber ansonsten ja.
Haben Sie Blut in der Urin bemerkt?
Blut in der Urin?
Nein, ist mir nicht aufgefallen, nein.
Haben Sie Müdigkeit oder Schwäche?
Nein, normalerweise nicht, nein.
Ist Ihre Periode regelmäßig?
Also da habe ich keine Probleme, nein.
Was war Ihre letzte Periode?
Das ist ungefähr 2 Wochen jetzt her.
2 Wochen.
Wann waren Sie bei Ihrem Frauenarzt?
Dann gehe ich jetzt nicht so oft, ich glaube, das war mal vor 4 Jahren, glaube ich.
Ich habe ja nie Probleme gehabt.
Okay, in Ordnung Frau Schneier, ich hätte ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Krankung geschickt.
Leiden Sie an einer bestimmten chronischen Erkrankung,
wie Bluthochterlukalkrankheit schilddrüsen Erkrankungen?
Nein, glücklicherweise habe ich bisher keine Erkrankungen,
ich nehme auch keine Medikamente.
Und daher bin ich eigentlich sehr glücklich.
Haben Sie sich schon einmal operiert oder in Frankenhaus Haus behandelt worden?
Also wie gesagt, bei diesem Fahrradunfall vor 3 Jahren bin ich gestört
und habe mein rechtes Handgelenk verletzt oder gebrochen.
Und das musste operiert werden.
Aber sonst habe ich keine anderen Operationen.
Nehmen Sie Schlafmittel, Berihugungsschmittel, Apfelmittel oder Schmerzmittel?
Bisher noch nicht.
Haben Sie Allergien oder Unverträglichkeiten?
Ich habe also nur Allergien gegen Colin und Gräser.
Und Gräser, Gras.
Wie sieht allergische Reaktion aus?
Ich kriege immer so Mücken in der Nase, meine Augen brennen.
Ich muss dann immer niesen.
Was nehmen Sie dagegen?
Also da habe ich so Allergietabletten, Zitirezin und das hilft mir eigentlich ganz gut.
Hat das geholfen?
Ja, das hilft mir.
Rauchen Sie Frau Schneider?
Nein.
Rauchen Sie, haben Sie geraucht früher?
Nein, nein.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Sehr, sehr selten.
Ich trinke jetzt nicht regelmäßig.
Aber wenn man bei einem Fest ist oder bei einer Feier,
dann trinke ich vielleicht ein Gläschen Wein, aber ansonsten nicht.
Rhythmisch muss ich fragen,
haben Sie Kontakt mit irgendwelchen Drogen gehört?
Nein, bisher noch nicht.
Bitte nicht perjurieren.
Alles gut.
Sie tun ja Ihre Pflicht, Herr Doktor.
Was sind Sie schon vom Beruf?
Ich bin, wie soll man das beschreiben,
eine Spezialistin für, wie sagt man dazu,
für Blumen und für Pflanzen, also eine Floristin.
Floristin?
Ja.
Arbeiten Sie jetzt oder Ruhestand?
Nein, nein, natürlich.
Ich arbeite schon.
Dazu für den Ruhestand bin ich noch zu.
Ich arbeite in einer Gärtnerei.
Entschuldigung.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Nein.
Haben Sie Partner?
Genau, ich habe einen Partner.
Wir haben keine Kinder, aber wir sind noch nicht verheiratet.
Wollen Sie allein oder mit wem wollen Sie?
Ja, mit meinem Partner.
Wir wohnen schon zusammen.
Jetzt möchte ich etwas über Familiengeschichte erfahren.
Herr Doktor, Sie möchten aber heute sehr viel wissen.
Muss ich fragen.
Die Schmerzen werden wieder schlimmer.
Jetzt kommen wir wieder die Kohle.
Können Sie mir etwas gegen die Schmerzen geben?
Ja, brav.
Schmerzmittel?
Oder ertragen Sie diese Schmerz?
Ein bisschen, aber Schmerzmittel werden mir jetzt lieber,
wenn Sie mir etwas geben können.
Vielleicht eine kleine Infusion?
Ja, ich habe Sie jetzt einen nonsteroidal Antinflammatoid.
Was ist das?
Das verstehe ich nicht, Herr Doktor.
Sind es Schmerztabletten oder sind es Medikamente?
Geben Sie mir einfach etwas gegen die Schmerzen.
Ein bisschen über die Infusion.
Ja, möglich.
Aber erst einmal, ich möchte einen nonsteroidal Antinflammatoid.
Was ist nonsteroidal Antinflammatoid?
Ich verstehe nicht.
Das ist es.
Zum Beispiel, ein medizinischer Sprach.
Das ist eine Schmerzmittel.
Ja, sagen Sie doch, dass es Schmerzmittel sind.
Ich bin kein Mediziner, Doktor.
Ich verstehe das nicht.
Ich möchte eine Infusion.
Das ist besser, das wirkt schneller.
Zweites Wahl ist Infusion Therapie.
Ich möchte lieber eine Infusion, bitte.
Das geht schneller.
Bitte.
Ist Ihnen schon besser?
Vielen Dank.
Ich habe doch gesagt, Infusion hilft mir.
Das ist schon viel besser.
Ich möchte weitergehen.
Ja, bitte schön.
Wenn Sie jetzt noch Fragen haben, dann können Sie die jetzt stellen.
Leider haben Familien angehörige, unwichtige Erkrankungen.
Zum Beispiel Zuckererkrankheiten, Bluthochdruck, Krebs und weiter.
Nein, nur mein Vater hat ein bisschen Bluthochdruck.
Ich weiß, er nimmt auch Medikamente.
Aber meine Mutter hat keine Erkrankungen.
Haben Sie noch Fragen, Doktor?
War das jetzt alles?
Keine Frage.
Nur haben Sie Geschwister oder Infungen?
Die Infungen sind, soweit ich weiß, alle gemacht.
Aber mein Hausarzt dreht sich danach.
Aber sonst habe ich nicht Geschwister.
Covid-19 geimpft?
Nein, ich hatte schon zweimal Covid.
Ich habe keine Impfung.
Ich will nicht.
Danke sehr.
Was ist das jetzt, Doktor?
Ist das etwas Schlimmes?
Ich verstehe, dass Sie sich sorgen.
Ich denke, Sie sind eine Öhrnertraginfekt,
Öhrnertrackentzündung oder Öhrnertraginfekt?
Was war eine Entzündung?
Entzündung, Zistitis oder...
Was ist eine Zistitis?
Ich verstehe nicht.
Ich könnte nicht auf eine normalen Sprache aussprechen.
Was ist eine Zistitis?
Urinentzündung.
Ach, Sie meinen, eine Hahnwegsentzündung?
Hahnwegentzündung.
Ach so, Herr Doktor.
Oder...
Differentialdiagnose kommen?
Was heißt Differentialdiagnose?
Ich verstehe das nicht, Herr Doktor.
Differentialdiagnose, was ist das?
Sie reden sehr medizinisch, Herr Doktor.
Sie sind ein netter Doktor, aber ich verstehe Sie leider nicht.
Was machen Sie noch Untersuchungen?
Wollen Sie Blut abnehmen?
Oder eine eigene Versuchung?
Schritt für Schritt mache ich Köpelheruntersuchung
und Status und Blutabnehmen und so weiter.
Was ist ein Urstatus?
Ich verstehe das nicht.
Urin...
Sie wollen Urin kontrollieren?
Ja, gut, vielen Dank.
Dann hoffe ich, dass da die Ergebnisse uns eine Diagnose zeigen.
Vielen Dank.
Dankeschön.
Bauen Sie noch eine Frage oder wollen wir gleich weitermachen?
Hat jemand noch Fragen?
Keine? Keine Fragen.
So sieht aus.
Okay.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Ja.
Haben Sie sich nicht mehr in der Blutung beim Gechness-Werkeh?
Nein.
Ich bin jetzt seit...
Ich habe schon längere Zeit keinen Sex gehabt, aber normalerweise ist alles in Ordnung.
Okay.
Haben Sie Rückreis im Gentilbereich oder Berennen?
Nein, nein. Nur beim Wasserlassen habe ich Schmerzen.
Okay, okay, danke.
Okay, das war es.
So.
Herr Doktor, sind Sie bereit, wollen wir gleich weitermachen?
Noch nicht bereit?
Noch nicht bereit.
So, Herr Doktor, sind Sie bereit?
Ja. Guten Tag, Herr Oberast.
Guten Tag, unsere Doktor hier. Hallo.
Guten Abend.
Wie geht es Ihnen?
Ich würde Ihnen gerne einen Patienten vorstellen.
Sie haben meine Patientin aufgenommen, sehr gut, sehr gut.
Dann erzählen Sie...
Wie ich gerade eben in der Ambulanz gesehen habe.
Okay.
Schreiner, Schreiner, 36 Jahre alt, 85 kg schwer und 1 m, 72 kg groß.
Ja.
Die Patientin stellt sich bei uns vor Aufgrund seit ein Wochen bestehender, plötzlich aufgetretener,
stark erschärzen in der linken Flanke.
In der linken Flanke, ja, okay.
Die Schmerzen, die Schmerzintensität wurde mit 7 und 8 von 10 auf der Schmerzskala bewertet.
Schon heftig, ja.
Was hat sie noch?
Sie wurden im Laufe der Zeit schlimmer geworden und auf die Tüte gehen, die Schmerzen schlimmer geworden.
Okay.
Ein, vor ein woher gehen Sie beim anderen Arzt?
Wartig, bei einem anderen Arzt.
Der Hausarzt?
Der Hausarzt, ich habe profen 600 verschreiben.
Beschrieben, okay.
Und die Patientin, nach diese Medikamente eingenommen, diese Schmerzen ein bisschen verdienen.
Das heißt, nach Einnahme der Schmerzdiskamente haben die Schmerzen etwas nachgelassen.
Okay.
Also, in der vegetative Anamnese, in der vegetative Anamnese,
kein Fieber, appetitiert also gut, gebt Veränderung noch nie.
Und sie haben Übelkeit und keinen Erbruch, Erbrechen.
Keine Sobrenen, keine Vögelgefühl, keine Herzprobleme, Aschikade oder uns weiter, Brustenge, keine Brustenge.
Okay.
Keine Sturkankprobleme und sie haben beim Wasserlassen eine Brenne und in der Nacht, 2 Mal, muss sie in der Toilette gehen.
Also zum...
Das heißt, sie hat eine...
Das heißt, sie hat eine Düsturi und eine Nücturi.
Yes, da, ja.
Okay.
Die Düsturi.
Hat sie auch eine Ausstrahlung der Schmerzen von der Flanke oder ist es nur an der Flanke?
Ich vergesse die Entspinung.
Okay, haben wir vergessen, okay.
Was haben Sie vergessen?
Beschreiben Sie das bitte?
Verschreiben, nein, nein.
Beschreiben Sie die Schmerzen bitte.
Die Schmerzen strahlen linken Bein und Oberbauch aus.
Oberbauch oder Unterbauch?
Unterbauch, ja.
Das klingt eher logischer, ja.
Entschuldigung.
Unterbauch aus.
Okay, und wie sind die Schmerzen?
Ist es nur eine Ausstrahlung oder ist es...
welche Qualität haben die Schmerzen, welche Eigenschaft haben die Schmerzen?
Die Schmerzen...
ich sei Wellen für mich und kollegartig.
Das klingt schon besser.
Okay, gut.
Okay.
Die Patientin würde dann vermeint...
...Hematurie...
und schlafen...
Stopp, die Patientin...
...verneint Hematuri.
Nicht...
Sie...
Sie habe keine Probleme...
mit Periode.
Okay.
Weil ist...
Ihre letzte Periode war...
war zwei Wochen.
Sie haben keine Probleme mit Periode.
Periode war war zwei Wochen...
Vor zwei Wochen, okay...
Sehr gut.
Sie haben keine...
keine Erkrankungen, wie Diabetes mei-litus...
Arterialhypertone usw.
Und keine Medikamente eingenommen.
Wie keine Medikamente eingenommen? Sie haben doch über Profen eingenommen, haben Sie doch gesagt.
Nur regelmäßig Medikamente.
Nehmt keine regelmäßigen Medikamente ein.
Entschuldigung. Aber Sie hätten vor drei Jahren eine Fahrradunfall.
Deswegen untergesoht, deswegen haben Sie eine Handgelenkfraktur nach dem Fahrradunfall.
Und deswegen wurde die Handgelenkfraktur operiert.
Ach so, das heißt, Sie hatten einen Sturz durch ein Fahrradunfall und aufgrund der Handgelenkfraktur wurde sie operiert.
Okay. War das alles oder haben Sie noch?
Ich war nie alles.
Allergie, Allergie, Anamnese. Entschuldigung.
Sie haben Polen und Gräser Allergie.
Und Gräser Allergie.
Diese Allergie, also Sie, allergische Konjektivität.
Und Sie nehmen dagegen eine Settelchen Tablete.
Das hat geholfen, Ihre Beschwerden, Ihre allergische Beschwerden.
Was habe gegen Ihre allergische Beschwerden geholfen?
Hat Sie auch eine Rinitis?
Nein, nur früher, wie gesagt.
Was möchten Sie sagen?
Sie sind auf Türkisch?
Erst im Jahr, nur Polen.
Sie hat im Frühjahr eine Polenallergie und im Rahmen dieser Allergie eine Rinitis.
Sie haben nicht...
Was hat sie nicht?
Sie rauchen nie.
Und sie trinken sehr selten Alkohol.
Weiser Wein.
Nicht Weiser Wein, ein Gläschen Wein.
Gläschen.
Ein Gläschen Wein.
Sie sind Floristin von Beruf.
Und jetzt lese ich und habe einen Partner.
Sie ist nicht lege, sie ist ein Partner.
Dann leben Sie im Partner zusammen.
Sie wohnt alleine.
Sie ist nicht verheiratet.
Sie ist nicht verheiratet, aber ein Partner.
Haben Sie noch etwas?
Sie haben noch eine Minute.
Was hat die Patientin Ihrer Meinung nach?
Was ist Ihre Arbeitstiagnose?
Ich denke, die Patientin aufgrund der Symptomatik.
Ich habe einen Verdacht auf einen Übeneretrakt.
Was ist Ihre Meinung nach?
Eine Pylonephritis.
Und?
Eine Zystitis.
Was kann sie noch haben?
Was können Sie noch haben?
Sie haben Schmerzen im Bereich der Flanke.
Sie haben eine Lumbolgie.
Was noch?
Sie sind noch der Arzt.
Sie haben eine Pylonephritis.
Was ist links?
Also das ist ja etwas Gynäkologisches, aber der will ja etwas anderes sagen.
Was ist das Gegenteil von appendicitis?
Diverticulitis.
Ja, genau.
Diverticulitis heißt links-seitige appendicitis.
Nicht heißt, aber so ist ähnlich.
Das könnte man verstehen.
Also etwas noch, gynäkologisch, was kann man noch gynäkologisch sagen?
Eine oberialzüste oder etwas noch?
Endometriosis.
Okay, was noch?
Phalfangitis.
Ja, natürlich, hier spricht eine Gynäkologin.
Bitte schön, was noch?
Also alle die gynäkologischen Erkrankungen kann man noch sagen.
Eine salpingitis, eine Omen,
eine Einblutung in die oberialzüste,
oder eine, wie nennt sich das, wenn sich die Eierstücke verdrehen?
Das hat sie aber nicht gehabt, das war immer normal, hat sie gesagt.
Ovaletorsium.
Genau, der sind begriff, habe ich gesagt, eine Ovariatorsium.
Also viele Möglichkeiten der Gynäkologischen Untersuchung.
Okay, gibt es noch etwas anderes noch?
Ich glaube, das reicht, oder?
Okay, vielen Dank, Herr Doktor.
Danke sehr.
Das war sehr gut für den ersten Versuch.
War sehr gut.
Aber Sie versuchen ein bisschen an der Grammatik,
an den Personen, eher Sie, vielleicht noch ein bisschen denken.
Sie können es gut, aber ich glaube, Sie müssen mehr sprechen.
Also nicht nur Medizinisch, sondern einfach die deutsche Sprache
ein bisschen flüssiger zu reden.
Sie kennen viele Wörter, Sie kennen auch viele Sätze
und kennen auch die Grammatik.
Gut, ich glaube, Sie haben gute Englischkenntnisse,
weil Sie immer wieder Englisch sprechen, zwischendurch.
Sprechen Sie gut Englisch?
Noch nie.
Okay.
Aber das ist gut, also je mehr Sie sprechen, umso besser wird es.
Danke sehr.